[Musique]
pourquoi je suis ici
oui parce qu'il faut que je fasse mon
devoir
il ya combien seulement 0 1% entre
survivants ce qui signifie que pour un
seul survivant diamil tués
si avant j'étais rongé par l'inquiétude
aujourd'hui j'ai bien peur qu'il y ait
simplement plus d'espoir pour vos
soldats
pour nous tous
[Musique]
comme vous le savez déjà un événement
s'est produit il ya vingt-quatre jours
nous avons perdu le contact avec la
quasi totalité du monde toutes les zones
à l'extérieur du cercle de vie ont été
plongés dans l'obscurité
[Musique]
tous ceux de la zone de quarantaine
devons nous attaquer
160 millions d humains
pas tout à fait
je ne sais absolument pas un conte doit
se préparer
si c'est trop dur avec moi
la guerre a commencé
[Musique]
j'aimerais le découvert à ma femme
la nouvelle impératrice de russie
[Applaudissements]
ça vous dit maintenant vous vous taisez
mon amour bien entendu c'est que des
fois une immense responsabilité est un
grand honneur d'être à la tête d'un
empire de cette importance je ne passais
compliqué c'est pourquoi je veux écouter
ceux qui ont un problème avec moi
adacore oublié mais j'aimerais être
utile à l'entière de russie contribue
elle s'agrandit vous allez porter mes
amitiés
vous êtes déjà utile c'est un gourdin
carte à augmenter la fertilité mais
j'hésitais ce qu'il faut que je vous les
agitent au dessus du ventre ou que je
les fours directement dedans je pense
que les agités devrait largement suffire
ils seront investis plus grande c'est
moi qui dirige vous êtes à mon service
votre épouse est malheureuse il faut que
vous discutiez ces nuages
il faut qu'on retrouve une amende
magnifique
je préfère être seul le matin tony
dorénavant nous accueillerons sans
religion nous devons nous aurons le
carat trépider saison d'hiver règles qui
tombe cette partie de chasse pour savoir
si on tue l'impératrice ou faire c'est
aussi une étrange créature qui je crois
a tendance à se moquer
sachez que vous n'êtes pas la seule à
être malheureuse beaucoup d'hommes ne
s'y retrouvent pas recouvert un vrai
dirigeant
si l'empereur moeurs l'empiré reviens tu
as atteint
et la russie doit vraiment être sourire
et moi avec
je ne veux pas vous tuer vous n'êtes pas
quelques mots ouais je pourrais 28 vous
n'êtes pas mauvais vous êtes pire vous
êtes drôle on est en train de parler
d'un acte de trahison
[Musique]
jouer un jeu dangereux
respirez goûter ravissement à la cour de
la grande catherine doors
dans la bulle vous voulez dire dans le
mille regardez la science rien que pour
vous
[Musique]
saut à des formations montagneuses
hainaut
tanus
[Musique]
c'est plutôt existants elle
le stemi de corse quand tu es spg
ce
nankin et l'osier
[Musique]
et
camer be en économie
[Musique]
quand il faut retirer
j'écris un livre voilà t'entraîner
craint des temps bon écoute ou vise pas
non mais non tu en a trop dit là alors
tu as tort j'ai deux éditeurs qui m'ont
appelé aujourd'hui rémy larmes c'est la
maison d'édition la plus prestigieuse
qu'elle très impressionné par votre
livre
je me disais si les alliés arrive pour
que pour moi je veux mais pas la
structure depuis qu'on en pense j'ai
plein d'idées la paul valéry dessiner
une demi-heure avant d'écrire rimbaud et
prenez de l'opium et moi je les cite les
packs à mâcon tu peux pas envoyer sa des
éditeurs le mariage montre qu'on va me
reconnaîtra
ian fowler j'essaie de faire sortir doit
se faire chier je serai à pau ne
tiendrait plus vite
j'étais tellement que la littérature
c'est pour moi ça me rend dingue que
jamais voler mon art et j'aimerais
vraiment que tu lises attendant qu'est
ce que c'est le moment la série où on va
comprendre qu'elle tue 1
j'ai écrit un livre il ya plein de gens
qui l'achètent juste où j'en suis très
bon truc précédent la casserole en fait
du coup là je passe à un peu à la télé
rien du tout moi ça va s'arrêter
tu m'offres la moto la chambre d'hôtel
et où je peux pas je peux pas être avec
anthony croit-il
on était bien comme on vivait avant bord
des annonces avant c'était simple je me
disais un truc à d'écouter ce livre je
pourrais faire une photo deux cent
cinquante mille exemplaires vendus je
crois que c'est rien du tout on voit
j'en ai plein des photos de toi tu
pelouse soit par board
absolument je vais mettre bonsaï
japonais pour sap est claire non c'est
ça c'est publié jeudi
moi je suis hyper publié non
mais injustement trouve pas que l'agro
sinon grosse tête
ah bah voilà tu vois toi aussi tu le dis
[Musique]
parmi les jeunes gens certains étaient à
lancieux notre chère patrie socialiste
leur avait donné la chance d'étudier
certains ont préféré sacrifier la vie de
personnes innocentes
on y va m'attendre
il
vous voulez pas savoir
zobrist ont
ou technique